ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi ho
pensato di proporre una ricetta
abbastanza famosa ma che solitamente
compro sempre al supermercato sto
parlando dei nachos con la salsa
guacamole ho trovato questa ragazza che
si chiama zeinab di fan page e lei usa
un procedimento molto molto semplice che
richiede i seguenti ingredienti farina
di mais un gattino del 36 dell'acqua
olio di arachide per mente dovrebbe
essere molto semplice come procedimento
200 g di farina di mais finissima senza
glutine addirittura mazza una sosta ton
esercito senza altare che stiamo girando
abbastanza presto
quindi ci metteremo a friggere questi
qui le classiche famiglie è stato pari a
marana rara aggiungiamo 200 millilitri
di acqua da far vedere che siamo
misurati
eri notturno ricordi mai metterla
grembiule 200 millilitri d'acqua che ti
rendi conto che in accesso sono
solamente acqua e farina di mais ragazzi
bisogna aggiungere un po di farina
fidatevi massima facendo precotta metri
cotta gianmarco questa farina è una
farina di mais giallo precotta non messo
cucchiaino di sale
forse un po più d'acqua serve c'è
francis sto aggiungendo altri buu
d'acqua il fatto è che gianmarco
gianmarco questa farina erano tutte
senza glutine che il glutine aiuta a
compattare le cose grazie mille
la prossima volta gianmarco cercheremo
di fare in baci perugina con dei sassi
al posto delle nocciole si può stendere
come ti sei permesso
sembra la pietra di fantaghirò è una
palla
la piazza tra due fogli e andiamo a
stendere la batteria lingua della è che
una volta che grande un'altra riesco a
mangiare e finita cosi preciso è bravo e
non si sollevano un attimo se capello ci
sono i sottotitoli juncata scherzo
stiamo per cambiare la ricetta perché io
questa qui non voglio portare a casa non
posso chiuderla così c'è queste persone
il corato nelle persone che credono in
atto cucina contendibile nell'igiene
dagli stessi quantitativi zanna si recò
a questo l'effetto de paris ciao ragazzi
il bentornato in una puntata di cucina
buttata oggi cercheremo di fare in asus
fatti in casa abbiamo bisogno di farina
di mais animali si in realtà non è
proprio così
farina 00 sale e poi servono
i semini che potete immaginare qui sono
al mio a mano in questo momento che
servono fondamentalmente per dare quei
puntini neri che a volte vedete che voi
invece immaginerete nella mia mano all
olio pure serve dell'odio ma è un olio
olio riproviamoci io ci credo ma mica
come ti chiami tu
mischa 150 g di farina di mais
[Musica]
ok 75 grammi di farina normale ed
improvvisamente non siamo più inutili
gluten free gluten dupont male così a
questo è il mio metodo di chi un pizzico
di sale semi polvere hoc
il cast ha indicato se gli ho già messi
6 2 cucchiai di olio mi faccio un occhio
pieno piano ok quindi dobbiamo ora unire
tutto quanto finché non è bello
amalgamato amalgamato
ruby ok il discorso è questo a kobe è un
altro livello
sento che proprio abbiamo fatto bene e
questa secondo me è una grandissima
allegorie nella vita cioè quando ti
rendi conto che stai sbagliando qualcosa
cambia non stare lì a cercare di
migliorare gli errori gli errori non si
migliorano il rifanno migliorare questa
è la nostra versione
diciamo la versione io sono un incontro
tra zaina e cina maga che nate a quello
che prevediamo si chiama nadia liscia si
sta un po un sasso però credo che sia
una cosa positiva usa i ragazzi io sono
supporti nico sì ma poi erano in pattini
oppure non c'erano dentro ci riproviamo
sera difficoltà de sto coso ora che è
molto sottile vediamo un pochino e chi
come ridiamo basterà pizza forchetta che
stanno 12 un altra roba sì sì sì c'è
senso anche se gianmarco non è preso la
giusta farina in questo modo abbiamo
quello che ci serviva gente motori del
successo
sì ma sa perché perché non sento odore
di gianmarco
no se rotto questo gianmarco si è
beccato le dosi giuste cioè divertente
da fare in compagnia con la
consapevolezza che a 1 euro
proprio un chilo di nagios ma non sai
che cosa c'è dentro qui invece sai che
c'è una farina sbagliata
e così è un'idea forse la serie di ditte
che si alzava così che abbassava sei tu
sei un automa se un robot rimasti
coltelli sono letali materia ruotati
l'arrotino come le ruote coltelli per
diceva se da quel macchinario che gira
capito quale le palle te l'ho detto la
sedia perché la sedia viene compressa
alto peso e quando ti alzi fa tto sta
pensando e la tua faccia le luci le luci
ragazzi quando si frigge c'è questo e
l'olio che si mette come dice parla chi
è tania norma sicuro dentro c'è qualcosa
approvate alla cottura di una finchè non
diventano belli dorati
allora tutti insieme sono venuti a
trovarmi altri cugini state per mangiare
nei nachos con la guerra molto delusa
scrittura alta così a potersi far cosa
farà adesso è stato affinché trovi negli
studi e per le morti troppo
ciao
[Musica]
[Risate]
mettiamo in ordine questo casino e
passiamo al guacamole allora gli
ingredienti sono un avocado online un
pomodoro dello scalogno sale in realtà
ci vorrebbe il peperoncino quello lì
grosso che t'ho tagli ma gianmarco aver
pensato di prendere del peperoncino
secco
i rangers manuel di giallozafferano
perché mi sono ispirato alla sua ricetta
quando dico ispiratori salute al sacco
piatto per intero mi raccomando ragazzi
avvocato bello maturo
è una tecnica ho visto fare per
tagliarlo bene è quella di tagliarlo
direttamente dentro
l'avvocato almeno questo è quello che fa
in mano il libro solitamente uso un
cucchiaino e lo tiro fuori il problema è
che poi devi tagliare e sporcare invece
questa è una cosa ancora più da pesa
culi quindi l'adoro presepe
studiate per bene puoi fare
a questo punto cucchiaio tornate sotto e
cominciare a tirare via tutto
prendiamo questo punto il lime veloci
veloci prima che si ossidi lo
massaggiamo in questa cosa mi dimentico
sempre rifare teoricamente si massaggia
per far uscire ancora meglio il succo ma
sarà così tanto cinema di lime 10
girarmi di succo no ma è giusto
nell'info box ragazzi mettiamo tutti
quanti gli ingredienti perché non si fa
un casino sale pepe che non avevamo tra
sta scendendo da carbonaro fatto e
schiacciamo il pensiero del mortaio
un'ascia anche per bene ma chef coba sei
stata bravissima assolutamente nuova
dopo pochi giorni
dovreste riuscire ad aver ottenuto un
composto morbido con qualche pezzetto ma
perché l'abbiamo scelto noi di tenere
qualche pezzetto aggiungiamo lo scalogno
tritato un po di pomodoro tagliato a
dadini aggiunge a questo punto un
peperoncino messicano tagliato proprio
al coltello
naturalmente tanto secondo mitch faccio
il mio ecco queste stesse mani a voi
piace tanto il piccante no un po d'olio
ferite non ho detto minimamente quelli
erano gli ingredienti all'inizio del
video mischiamo no si sa è bello e
questo dovrebbe essere il risultato dire
a questo punto di fare un assaggio
nachos fatti in casa con guacamole fatta
in casa
smetti abbondate di sasso tetto è buona
ciao
notato come la mole e squisita e qui
invece potete provare questi sono
veramente grossi però la sala sarei
fatta bene sono strani non sembrerebbe
deciso di tempo presso le piace e non è
in forse qualunque cosa sia è buono e
questi come sono certo non mi interessa
il tuo parere non ho da vede tre quinti
dei vip
allora questo è tuo
zero a zero ma sicuro dei ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video
nell'info box metterà tutti quanti gli
ingredienti che sono stati utilizzati
sia per inacio schepp e la salsa
guacamole come sempre vi invito se
doveste provare anche voi a fare inacio
sola salsa o quello che vi pare
attaccarmi in su instagram mandarmi
hostess tories le foto quello che vi
pare iscrivetevi a questo canale
attivate la campanella
se non volete perdere i prossimi video
noi ci vediamo la prossima domenica
sempre con un'altra puntata di cucina
buttata ciao